في ظرف 120 دقيقه تجوب هذه الحافله
السياحيه المعالم الاسلاميه والمواقع
التاريخيه والاثريه للمدينه المنوره
ليتعرف على متنها الزوار حكايا وقصص مدينه
الرسول
خمس حافلات تعمل ضمن برامج الرحلات
السياحيه الداخليه لزوار واهالي المدينه
المنوره عبر 12 مسارا لتعريف الركاب على
مجموعه كبيره من المعالم في مقدمتها
المسجد النبوي وجبل احد وجاده قباء صراحه
فكره جميله جدا ومميزه وحاجه جديده في
المدينه بالساهل على زائر المدينه اللي
جاي من جده او من الرياض او من اي منطقه
من مناطق المدينه من خارج المملكه بيسهل
عليه ان الباص يوديه مزارات المدينه
ويرجعه تاني يكمل فروته صلاته في الحرم في
خلال 120 دقيقه انا شخصيا استفدت منها في
اماكن ما كنت اعرفها
واطلعت عليها عن طريق الباص السياحي في كل
محطه لك الامكانيه في ان تنزل وتستكشف على
راحتك المكان الذي
يتواجد قرب المحطه وتترك البسيط يذهب
وتستانف رحلتك عند البصل القادم او الذي
بعده المهم ان رحلتك لا تضيع مع تزايد
الاعداد الملحوظ بموسم العمره هذا العام
كثفت الحافلات السياحيه بالمدينه المنوره
من جولاتها اليوميه التي تعمل على مدار
اربعه عشره ساعه دون توقف
من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات